[Music]
it's
fine it's
cool you can say that we are nothing but
you know the truth and guess
I'm the
fool with their arms are like an angel
through the clom room I don't want to
call it off but you don't want to call
it love you only want to be the one that
I call
[Music]
baby
boys another sh to stop the feeling you
can sayange just the way you are make
can excuse the stupid
reason yeah the world just stop the
feeling
good
good yeah just stop the world just to
stop the feeling
say who cares it's just sexually
explicit got a love a fair and I cry
it's not fair I just need a little love
and I just St a little
L think I'm going to call it all even if
you
love I just love someone who calls me
baby
boys another shout to stop the feeling
you can change just the way you
are excuse St reason
good
good yeah just stop the world just to
stop the feeling good
[Applause]
yeah the world just stop
feel you wake up next to him in the
middle of the night with your head in
your hands you nothing more is wi and
when you think about me I love those
years it go you're standing F to f with
I told you so you know I hate to say I
told you so you know I hate to say but I
told you
you
boys
I way you
are
St good good
yeah just the world just to stop the
feeling
good
good yeah just the world just to stop
the feeling yeah just the world just to
stop the feeling you have to stop the
world just to stop the feeling you have
to stop the world just to stop the
feeling
[Music]
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
session goodness only knows I enjoy
creating it uh real quickly I just want
to put a huge thank you out there to
ultra poy for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to go out and flow
in different awesome spots in DC if
you'd like to grab a set of those orb
poy Pros that I was using in this video
you can get 10% off the price of those
POI by using the code drexfactor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout once
again that is drexfactor with a zero
instead of an O you can do that over at
ultra.com thank you once again to ultra
PO for sponsoring this video and
speaking of thank yous uh big thanks go
out to the Friends of the channel
specifically big thanks go to uh dark
monk flow fests flow toys pyro Tera
light toys and uh Ultra poy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these amazing companies by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca becklen thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission finally this video
would not be possible without theing
support of my wonderful supporters on
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now thank you all
so very much and if you out there
watching are not currently supporter but
you'd like to become one you can do that
by heading on over to my patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor poy and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards but better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you you if
you'd like to check out some more of my
flow performances I will go ahead and
leave a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
yourself today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace